Andy and Hayley LeBlanc here now at the
streamys red carpet how does it go to be
here you guys it's bigger and better I
feel like everybody's outfit so far I
really just got here and I just love
like me have people's outfit there were
those so many animal you know the night
is young you know it could happen
actually um what does it mean to be here
in this room you guys with your
community on a night like this we get to
get gussied up a little I personally
came from set today I was on a show
you're working and I don't have a dress
so this is like wardrobes I went to from
a friend a friend gave it to me I was
pretty stressed I don't know how this is
gonna work out what you guys turned it
out uh Annie you have been very busy
though you just dropped a music video
right for your new song what was it like
having actually join you for that
project the chances you can be in one of
his films next maybe a little Shazam too
I do have a question for you though does
the family approve of Asher spending the
holidays together
[Music]